[Musique]
c'est un italien vous allez dire à 8
mois alors là parlez-moi italien je vais
fermer les yeux je vais craquer
complètement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous préférez les mecs beau gosse les
mecs intelligents les mecs comme moi bah
alors que vous êtes intelligent et beau
gosse comme vous en plus vous êtes
habillé manoir pour moi pour vous
l'unique membre où j'ai l'habitude de
chamblanc oui alors qu'elle est qu'elle
est la meilleure phrase monica pour vous
abordez pas de me dire je serai ton
fiscale facile
l'endroit idéal pour vous donner un
premier rendez-vous qui imaginez que
vous donnent rendez vous puisque bon là
on a un petit peu tous les deux alors un
restaurant parce que j'aime bien manger
d'accord oui c'est vrai à lyon c'est
vrai vous aimez bien manger c'est que
génial cet épicurien une brutale hier
j'ai des pâtes
le geste qui vous fait craquer chez un
homme les gestes qui me fait craquer un
peu les larmes aux yeux un homme qui
pleure vrai nom ça ne laisse pas tiré et
la plage en france pas j'essaye de un
geste
je parle ça peut être par une caresse
même égard est ce qu'on se ferait à soi
ça peut te faire craquer mais pas le
geste qui trahi votre trouble
ag je deviens rouge géologie jeu des
plaques partout ohlala oui mais dans ce
cas vous êtes comme ça c'est que vous
êtes troublé par l'homme qui est en face
à côté où elle a du sens qui monte à
laquelle l'alcool qui vous montre le
plus rapidement la tête à tout parce
qu'un effet je ne bois pas trop et un
mailing donc à lui être qu'elle est la
ville la plus romantique selon vous
monica rome paris rome et paris le
quartier où on a le plus de chance de
vous rencontrer l'art port à l'aéroport
bien le compliment qu'il ne faut jamais
vous faire j'aime tous les compliments
sont jamais assez les compliments celui
qu'on vous a jamais fait je crois qu'on
doit inventer
[Musique]